I know that uh there's been like many
times over throughout the history of
Jackass wild boys You Name It Whatever
we've been doing we've thrown out the
piece of information that you speak
fluent German but I'm guessing still
people don't know that is that I think
so yeah no it's still it still comes up
like I've gone on trips I was previously
sponsored by Monster Energy and they
would send me all over the world and I
went to Germany one time
and the lady who was uh with me like you
know hosting me or whatever was there
and she's like I've been with you all
these years and we'd landed in Germany
and I just started talking German to the
people there and she's like I never know
you spoke German I'm like well you never
asked right and and if if I remember
correctly you're uh from Italy I was
born in Italy right so my I'm an army
brat my dad was in the Army he was first
stationed in Germany where he met my mom
and then he got uh transferred and
stationed in Italy and that's when I was
born I was conceived in Germany but born
in Italy got it and uh it was German
your first language no it was my second
I didn't even want to learn it when I
was a kid but I did learn it real young
you know when you're a kid and you're
asking your mom what's this my mom would
tell me in German and I'd be like no not
that funny language what is it
okay so so let's feed we then let's feed
him some lines to stay in uh in Germany
yeah what was some of the [ __ ] they were
saying over there like uh say
um pull on my balls how do you say pull
on my balls
um I don't know balls like nuts what
about like isn't kitchen coochie
no kitchen is Cookie
yeah
or kicking kitchen like you cooking is
Cookie and kitchen is kuchen
okay say say it like a sentence like
give us something
oh uh
I'm here okay
all right that sounded pretty good but
say but I want to hear like some naughty
[ __ ] like uh like that and his [ __ ] is
schizen right [ __ ] it's shiny and and
we've always made jokes about it's so
crazy because we don't know you speak
German like most people but everybody we
can't say enough about German shizen
movies what's the story with German
sheisen movies because Germany like the
Germans are like the naughtiest they're
they're like the they're like the ones
that'll do the like [ __ ] on my face and
stuff like that that's where it's come
from that's why Shizu movie came from
that should I say [ __ ] on my face in
German
off
just touch it really quick yeah just
touch it really quickly touch it
Bruno Mars por favor
just kiss it for a second
oh
uh oh well kiss it for a second it's
like I'm second okay it's like yeah yep
get ready this is gonna be gnarly that's
pretty gnarly kind of gnarly are we
ready yeah
oh my God
what's up Denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on Instagram so I figure I should
be able to paint my dick and do whatever
I want
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I [ __ ] up
[Music]
I'm not doing this to hurt you Dad and
I'm not gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off